então apesar do miguel tem falado aqui
o mestrado em design a graduação em
gastronomia eu queria dizer que eu sou
essencialmente um cozinheiro e tem muito
orgulho disso e é esse que eu vou tentar
passar para vocês hoje
então quando a gente fala em de
desconstrução da gastronomia a gente tem
uma certa idéia daquele chefe inventor
aquele chefe que transformava um prato
tradicional pegava os mesmos
ingredientes que apresentava com
texturas e sabores inusitados brincar um
pouco com aquela questão a de que é o
prato ele seria como se fosse um palco e
que tudo aquilo que aconteceria nele
seria provocar um pouco o sentimento das
pessoas um pouco das suas emoções
então esse tipo de gastronomia embora
ainda seja muito popular é uma coisa que
é que a gente tem que discutir um
pouquinho e essa essa gastronomia de
desconstrução ela casou com um período
do dia de firmamento da da profissão de
cozinheiro como uma carreira de valor
porque até então ser cozinheiro não era
uma profissão de grande valia porque as
pessoas trabalhavam em cozinha porque
elas precisavam é considerado um
subgrupo então quando as pessoas viram
que aquela aquela posição poderia ser
algo interessante e que poderia fazer
diferença na vida das pessoas é que
houve uma necessidade de aprimorar ação
no que dizia respeito à educação e para
se ter uma idéia apenas em 1980 e uma
mulher conseguiu ingressar num curso de
hotelaria aqui no brasil que foi a benê
e ela veio a se tornar uma mancha muito
respeitada e até o termo chefe essa
nomenclatura que que acabou sendo
elevada ao status que a gente conhece
hoje é o que a gente precisa
desconstruir
então há o que a gente precisa entender
é o que seria a gastronomia a gente não
pode resumir a ela apenas um prato
experiência ou ou na figura de uma
pessoa que essa pessoa na verdade ainda
é um personagem é então a por causa
disso trouxe um exemplo que não
aconteceu há pouco tempo foi bastante
tempo e já o desenvolvimento do japão
como um estado nação
ele teve que o japão teve que fazer uma
reestruturação da sua alimentação por
causa do período das guerras e de como
eles deveriam aproveitar melhor os
insumos e de como a população poderia se
beneficiar disso porque é a a priori
deles é o seguinte uma população sadia
significava um exército forte então as
pessoas tinham a força para viver
elas poderiam ter forças para lutar
então esse foi o grande motivo por trás
da dessa implementação do sistema
alimentar japonesa que eles valorizavam
os insumos regionais associava as
preferências alimentares dos soldados e
aplicaram transformar isso num sistema
de planejamento 1 são de política
alimentar
logo depois para implementar escolas
hospitais e fábricas
então no início não era uma um ato
romântico japonês não a gente não é tão
cor-de-rosa assim no início e se cria um
exército eles queriam ter pessoas fortes
para poder lutar se eles precisassem que
ela vem da prova da boa parte em que o
exército de março através do estômago
essas pessoas têm tem força pra pra ver
os poderem votar
e aí a gente comece a se questionar como
é que a gente está se alimentando hoje
como é que ele está se alimentando
quais são as consequências das nossas
escolhas hoje o que a gente pode fazer
para alterar isso porque hoje em dia
está meio estressado meio corrido com as
cores do trabalho está distraída com
confaz [ __ ] a gente está muito
preocupado com a manhã sem a gente focar
no hoje e isso acaba causando um negócio
que é que foi discutido hoje com a
doutora b3 então a
são das doenças quem está preso num
ciclo que vai do trabalho alimentação
farmácia ea gente fica nesse círculo
vicioso ea gente não pára pra pensar o
que a gente está fazendo de errado e
como é que a gente pode projetar
sistemas que alavanque mudanças talvez
isso seja o mais importante hoje
então pra isso a gente vai estudar as
três dimensões da no que diz respeito à
gastronomia como é que a gente pode
fazer a nossa parte pra melhor essa
história porque ao contrário do que a
gente possa pensar não é só a respeito
da cozinha que a gente vai falar sem a
cozinha apresenta ela pra vocês e
apresentadas as verdades digamos assim
então imagine a seguinte situação talvez
você já deve ter passado por esse dia
das mães uma cantina de massas italianas
votação de 200 pessoas
então vocês podem imaginar que ele
estava lotado de pessoas às famílias
almoçando e os garçons aquela
coreografia de leva e traz os alimentos
tudo correndo muito muito suave
aquela coisa bem bonita bem romântica e
aí a gente entra na cozinha se alguém
nunca entrou na cozinha no horário de
rush
as pessoas talvez ficariam
impressionados com o caos panelões
bufando cozinheiros correndo pra lá e
pra cá os garçons entrando na cozinha e
gritando com os cozinheiros
o chef batendo boca com o garçom que
entrou invadindo o território dele
então esse tipo de ambiente é muito
cruel é muito duro ele exige o máximo
das pessoas que os turnos de trabalho
eles são são horríveis 12 14 16 e 18
horas
então isso agride psicologicamente
fisicamente os cozinheiros a agente se
corta vento esquema mas isso pra quem
opta por viver pela gastronomia e isso
vira uma verdade as pessoas vivem com
muito orgulho
olha só essa queimadura no braço isso
aqui é de massa que foi forma então é
esse tipo de coisa muito legal ea
premissa que se um restaurante tem uma
amazônia legal se é por causa do chef de
cozinha
mas isso é uma meia verdade
é uma meia verdade porque há por trás do
chef de cozinha
a gente tem uma grande equipe o
resultado desse trabalho ele sempre vai
ser proporcional ao espírito que o tse
que essa equipe carrega
então se eles não vêem no líder algo que
mereça ser empregado esforço não vai ser
tão forte assim ea gente pensa assim
o pessoal todo bonito e arrumado então
parece uma opção bacana da amorosa e aí
a gente começa a falar do amor na há a
figura do chefe de cozinha todo o
arrumadinho
isso aqui é a casa do amor é isso aqui a
essa é a cara do amor na verdade é quase
a expressão de dor mas aqui é na verdade
a gente faz isso porque a gente gosta
então não existe o amor mas o glamour
ali ele aparece por causa que é ele
aparece por uma coisa chamada alta
gastronomia que talvez vocês já ouviram
falar mas é que ela se baseia quase que
numa fantasia uma coisa meio tópica de
de cozinheiros quando o segredo pra
vocês que a gastronomia ela autografa
nela uma grande viragem certo ela
financeiramente a escada é muito difícil
de ser executada então ela praticamente
inviável
poucos conseguem fazer com que ela seja
um sucesso e que ainda consiga ser a
rentável a longo prazo isso é movido
muito também pela figura na verdade é um
personagem pressionarem estereotipada do
chef de cozinha é esse cara que a gente
tem que desconstruir é um cara que faz a
da astronomia do ego da publicidade em
que todos os pratos na verdade são são
superficiais eles não têm uma história
pra contar
eles não trazem as pessoas eles não
conectam a território a saúde ea cultura
das pessoas e é isso que a gente precisa
a gente precisa de pessoas que entendam
que essa gastronomia e que consiga
inspirar quem está entrando no mercado e
fazer
trabalhar em equipe em favor de um
objetivo principal e agora começa a
repassar um pouco das responsabilidades
também para vocês porque a gente não
está aqui de graça não vou repassar a
responsabilidade só para os cozinheiros
então falar um pouco do do poder que
vocês têm como clientes e é um poder que
a gente chama de legitimação quando
vocês forem para qualquer tipo de
estabelecimento em que tudo tenha que
dar o teu dinheiro eu sou adivinho
dinheiro em troca de um alimento isso é
um contrato de parceria isso é um
contrato de apoio então vai lá faz foi
diga olha fez foi me ver um lanche e
aqui está o dinheiro porque eu apóio a
cadeira produtiva e eu gosto do seu
método de de lidar com os funcionários e
eu acho isso muito bonito então aqui
está meu dinheiro pra te é isso que
significa quando faz uma escolha dessa
vez a gente não pense nisso por causa da
correria do dia a dia que a gente está
muito distraído ou não tem tempo pra
parar mas a gente precisa enxergar o que
está simbolizado que é o poder da
escolha
e aí mais um exemplo a gôndola de frutas
importadas os pecados a gente tem perdas
de maçãs da argentina ajudou o rio
grande do norte é a que mais a pitaia da
colômbia
tudo isso tem uma pegada de carbono
muito alta
a gente não não ver isso mas está
embutida
o bebê filho japão japão
a gente pensa
o teu escalope de comer vez andou 17.400
cinco anos para chegar no seu prato
sendo que a gente conseguiria ter um
carnê similar de altíssima qualidade
aqui do nosso próprio território
porque a gente faz essas escolhas então
por que compra isso é por isso que a
gente está aqui hoje que a informação é
como se fosse uma radiação do bem
ela contamina então a gente ela é causa
nas nossas escolhas é por isso que a
gente tem que saber o que está
consumindo e espalhar e é por isso que
eu considero momento de hoje como muito
propício para a ampliação de uma
gastronomia de resistência em nazaré
falou hoje cedo então a resistência ela
passa pela educação que ela tem que
trazer um pouco da ciência da teoria
para dentro da cozinha trazer a
criatividade em busca de uma das
economias inovadora gastronomia que
traga a a prática que traga a um pouco
da do conhecimento técnico científico
mas que pense nessa conexão do
território da saúde e das pessoas daqui
por último longa em último lugar
a gente tem que considerar nossa terra
você já foram à feira
sabem quantas vezes ela se realiza por
semana
sabia que mesmo nas feiras existem
produtos com altíssima pegada de carbono
nem todas são daqui
é óbvio que é que alguns dos produtores
não vão dizer então a gente tem que
questionar
pergunte para os produtores da onde vem
seu produto como é que tú cultiva ele
quando um produtor de base agroecológica
recebe a pergunta dessas ver o sorriso
no olho dele porque essa maneira que
eles escolheram de e dar acolhimento de
maneira harmoniosa com a natureza é
muito gratificante eles sabem que que
existem maneiras mais fáceis de fazer a
produção mas eles optam por não porque
eles têm um objetivo principal na vida
que a harmonia do meio ambiente e mesmo
assim ter uma
uma fonte de sobrevivência então a gente
tem que conhecer os nossos produtos
conhecer a sazonalidade
conheci fazer esse questionamento dos
agricultores em prol da nossa cultura
e aqui mais outra tarefa pra vocês
e essa que vocês não têm como escapar
análise o extrato do cartão de crédito
que vocês todas as escolhas alimentares
todas mas boa parte delas não está não
tem como fugir dos hotéis bares
restaurantes tudo o que vocês optaram
por apoiar estará então quando vocês
forem para o estabelecimento tenta
entender o que esse estabelecimento está
protegendo o que esse estabelecimento
está favorecendo na medida que tudo dá o
teu dinheiro tá apoiando
então é um contrato de parceria em favor
de uma cultura que seja totalmente nossa
totalmente sustentável e aí a gente se
lembra do caso do japão que eles fizeram
isso que não era uma atitude romântica
mas que com o passar do tempo e isso
tornou a astronomia japonesa com uma
potência cultural é é um modo de ver a
gastronomia ela não é mais uma
ferramenta de sobrevivência e aqui a
gente começa a se questionar sobre o que
seria então a gastronomia brasileira
qual é a identidade da gastronomia
brasileira
muito se dias que a gente tem que
construir uma identidade sendo que na
verdade a gente não sabe nem o que
coloca no próprio prato
então a gente tem que primeiro entender
qual é a nossa cultura local
qual é os valores que a gente está
colocando nossa própria casa para depois
falar de uma gastronomia regional e
depois uma identidade brasileira
aí um conselho na verdade conselho é um
pedido dos meus colegas de trabalho
profissão se vocês estão sendo chefes ou
cozinheiros porque muita gente se diz
chefe mas não é cozinha na essência para
os educadores se vocês estão ensinando
viver a gastronomia
diferente de ensinar técnicas
gastronômicas e aí pra vocês nossos
clientes
se as nossas escolhas estão sendo de
acordo com aquilo que a gente deveria
fazer o que precisa se alimentar para
passar o dia
é muito aliás é muito pouco então
ampliando um pouco mais há a questão da
resistência eu digo que há resistências
já começou e ela precisa da participação
de todos nós
obrigado
[Aplausos]